hi herzlich willkommen bei schön schlau
heute mal ein bisschen anders heute
verrate ich euch wer eigentlich hinter
schön schlau steckt
ich bin die mai ich bin chemikerin
ich habe vor paar wochen meine
doktorarbeit abgegeben zu dem thema an
modische polyurethane für physikalische
und ich möchte meine neu gewonnene zeit
damit verbringen euch mit wissenschaft
zu infizieren
doch schön schlau ist aber ein duo und
zwar ein m&m duo darf man eminems im
öffentlich-rechtlichen rw das zweite
entsteht führen wer dani melanie ist die
sehr talentierte scribble artistin art
ist es die die ganzen coolen animationen
für unsere videos macht und sich auch um
musik und sound kümmert und ich bin mir
nicht ganz sicher aber ich glaube dass
wir zu den kleinsten produktionen bei
funk gehören wenn nicht sogar die
kleinsten sind wir sind wirklich nur zu
zweit funktioniert so melanie und ich
wir überlegen uns die themen
beziehungsweise wir wollen euch hiermit
auch dazu aufrufen ihre themenvorschläge
mit uns zu teilen also was interessiert
euch ich recherchiere das dann
ich lese auch die wissenschaftlichen
originalquellen nach und dann nehme ich
tatsächlich viel zu hause in meinem
zimmer form einer weißen wand das video
auf schneide ist dann schicksal melanie
und die legt dann animation und sound
rüber eigentlich wollten wir heute auch
ein normales wissens video zusätzlich
rausbringen
allerdings wurde die arme melanie diese
woche von fieber und einer
mandelentzündung erwischt und nach
komplett flach deswegen schreibt ihr
eure lieben gute besserung grüße in die
kommentare damit sie sich schnell wieder
erholt ansonsten geht es nächsten
donnerstag regulär weiter das heißt wenn
ihr uns noch nicht abonniert haben dann
tut es jetzt damit los in zukunft nicht
verpassen